if a man's providing for you paying the
bills taking care of you and he steps
out would you stay in the relationship
or would you
leave the relationship
i i wouldn't stay in the relationship
because from my perspective my emotional
needs would be disturbed too much and i
think my own mental health would
definitely be compromised because for me
me personally a relationship's about
trust and when i enter into any
relationship whether or not it would be
a friendship or a romantic relationship
there has to be trust and once that
trust is broken then
i'd mentally find that very difficult to
be around that person because i'd always
be second guessing myself and what
they're doing so i personally couldn't
do it because i also wouldn't want to
impact on them and because i know i'd be
a certain way and i'd probably be
you know more
i'd not be happy and that would impact
their happiness so i wouldn't stay in
the relationship
so would you just leave or would you
like
demand certain
like respects be upheld in a
relationship
i think it depends i've been cheated on
in the past and i tried to work it out
with the individual i was very young at
the time but it didn't work out and
i held this
resentment towards him and so he became
very unhappy he wanted to stay with me
but he also lied throughout the whole
process about the whole thing
um he he wouldn't and it was going back
to he didn't want to lose me
um but what it did was it really
affected my mental health and confused
you yeah for a very long time and it and
i'm not gonna lie affected future
relationships after that i'm over it now
it was a very traumatic time i mean
would you would you like thinking like
going back right now would you go back
into the relationship now knowing that
like was he good enough to like stay in
the relationship even though he
you know i mean because sometimes it's
like girls would leave the relationship
because he's cheating even though the
relationship is 10 10 it's like
everything's going right but he just
stepped out like it's like would you are
you just going to leave that like it
wasn't a good relationship if i'm honest
we were both super young and it was very
toxic and and we were both very toxic
for each other i was toxic he was toxic
and i hope that i definitely learned
from that relationship and i hope that
he did too
it it was very sad the way everything
ended but i just think if you know it's
going to affect both your mental health
just don't just don't be in it if you
can't handle it and you know further
down the line you're constantly going to
be bringing things up just just don't do
it because
fundamentally happiness over everything
right and if you can't be happy don't be
together it might hurt in the first
instance to like separate but it will be
better in the long run for both of you
i mean what what causes girls to be in a
relationship right now then because i
find a lot of girls are single right now
and the the problem for most girls is
like i don't trust guys i don't trust
but you know what we're like like i mean
like okay it's because
all women
are dating the same guy
so there's no
like the dating pool for men is this big
and then
we have all these requirements they got
to be this tall look like this make this
much money so it makes a pool smaller
and smaller smaller so women are dating
the same guy from that pool because
more women want this type of guy this
high value guy than they do this one
over here and so
once this woman dates it oh that man's
trash the next that man's trash because
it's just the same type of men i get you
yeah but if all women are chasing the
same guy that guy should be in demand
why why then should he change for you
like i don't do you know like a man it's
not gonna like a woman is not gonna
really necessarily she doesn't want to
change for a man he should he should
accept her for who she is but the woman
is not accepting him for who he is you
know he's a 10 man you know bear geller
on him you know he could get if he wants
you know he could exercise his options
you know he's got money on him you know
he could go away you know he's talking
in the thing you know he's got bear gal
so why are you trying to change him and
then at the same time you're trying to
change him you don't want to change
yourself and but the thing is on the
flip side of that is like as a matter of
fact that's what actually attracted you
to the guy yeah you were attracted to
that guy because he was the guy that all
the girls wanted everybody knows they've
been school would have been college
there's a certain type of guy in college
and school
that got all the girls but i get that
but what my point hold on hold on
i need to say this i need to say this
no you say oh yeah but listen
no no no because you want you want your
point to be heard no you're not you're
not you're not you're not you're not
getting up speaking to the mind but
you're not listening
no i i i i'll give you an ample time
let's start off
what i'm saying is like um if women
understand that they're going for the
same types of guys right they know that
they're going to get the same types of
results which is one of the reasons why
a lot of women fight over men they don't
fight over
the other
fifty percent of men they're fighting
over that top ten percent which is why
women always get themselves into fights
over men they're fighting over the men
that album other women
so the thing is is that
it's a catch-22 because
they want this type of guy but they
don't
understand what it takes to be with that
type of guy and that type of guy like
you said he's got a lot of options right
he's got a lot of
options and women need to kind of
understand that that's part and parcel
of being with that type of guy but they
want to make that guy
exclusive to them mm-hmm they think that
they can change it they think that they
can they think that that's the one
potential to them
it's not going to work so like i've said
before on this podcast yeah there is at
least a 40 percent to 50 of men
that women are totally missing but
average dude i would put you in there
say again i would put you in that top
percent man based on what um yeah i just
say that i am who i am but i'm saying
there's a there's a 50 of men that women
are just they walk past them on the
street they don't want their attention
they don't even want to hear from these
types of guys those are the types of
guys that i will actually marry you come
on that top ten percent of guy yeah
marrying you because he's got too many
options why are you single
why am i single yeah i was in a 10-year
relationship bro you're you're one of
you i just came out of it i'm not i'm
i'm i'm chilling
question for you then why why are you
single
silent
no there's not silence at all i know 100
why i'm single girl right now if i go
through my instagram i've got about 10
girl i could be girls right now
girlfriends sorry 100 exclusive if i
wanted to be exclusive but right now i'm
enjoying my freedom and i'm enjoying
multiple how long have you been enjoying
your family before what multiple women
how long have you been enjoying your
freedom
i'm
i mean i've been enjoying too long bro
bro
until we're seven
too long but we can enjoy until we're
seventeen i'm a prime bro well we're men
bro
[Applause]
i will i will say that
i know we're different can i tell you
the trouble with that though
you say you're
you're in your field yeah
i'm in my prime i'm enjoying myself yeah
having the lit career
yes get me i mean the prem all right
good for you the problem the problem
number comes here when you
when you
you're gonna meet someone you're gonna
meet a woman yeah he's gonna strike you
and you're gonna be like okay i wanna
come out of that now yeah come into the
field yeah
you have you have
baggage
30 35 years plus of baggage of you being
out there in the field when it's not
going to be time for you to come in the
barn yeah you will have so many problems
yeah because you have built habits you
have built characteristics within within
yourself that when you're gonna want to
have that serious relationship you won't
be able to what serious relationship i
never said i wanted a rich serious
relationship okay if you don't want to
be in terms of one serious relationship
if i want multiple serious relationships
that's you
that's you that's true
that's you i'm trying to i'm trying i'm
trying to that's you that's fair
it's your life let me just let me finish
let me finish it's your life girls
you can do you can do what you want yeah
my my trouble is here i have
again
i meant to a lot of young men and they
feel like they can do this thing yeah
where
they will be out playing on the field
yeah for so long and then
knowing that they would want to be in
that silhouette if you don't want to be
in a serious relationship that's fine
great but multiple what what multiple
strokes
he wants to be polygamy
all right that's on you i'm trying to
say that i'm the person that wants to be
with one person yeah don't want to be
monogamous i want to be with one person
yeah when it's going to be time for you
yeah to do that you won't be able to bro
because you've built so many habits so
many bad characteristics yeah you're
going to end up hurting the woman that's
what i'm trying to say to you practice
that from now don't wait until you're 40
35 70 and then say all right i'm ready
because you won't be able to do it but
if you don't do you know if that's what
you're on then do you are you single
i'm single by choice
okay
what i'm saying yeah that's cool but are
you currently building bad habits right
now
no i'm actually trying to get rid of bad
habits that's what i'm saying what i'm
saying why are you celibate or something
have you never had sex before marriage
i'm a virgin you're a vet
it's a lie
why is it lie again again again thank
you thank you for being here
do you know where it is you know
everyone said that to you everyone has
to be alive yeah i always told me you're
like why because you're a virgin i'm a
virgin how old are you i'm 25 of respect
you're a virgin at 25. but you know
what's mad
it's not let me tell you it means that
he has no contribution in terms of how i
see my because i work with women bro
hold on
there's a difference between chilling
with women yeah and sleeping with women
they have completely different
relationships yeah bro completely
different trust you're allowed to get
away with certain so much different
stuff when you sleep with them as
opposed to being friends with them
there's a barrier that you have to keep
yeah and i'm saying to you in terms of
multiple women i want to look after
multiple women i don't want to just
cheat with multiple i want to look after
have kids with multiple women i want to
have a broad family i want to i want all
of them to be fine i want them to be
perfect it's not just
i'm just sleeping around no bro there's
a maximum to matter so question though
you're a virgin are you waiting on
marriage or something too i am yeah
you're waiting on marriage so it's a
christian thing it's not even a
christian thing it's a personal decision
i rate that that i've made since i was
young that i'm going to wait for you
until until i'm married right now so um
would you now prefer like
your partner to be a virgin also
no why what
it doesn't matter to me
it doesn't matter it doesn't matter to
me whether she is or not it doesn't
matter to me
it doesn't matter what is the girl gets
the hardest it is for her to pair bond
and the harder it is for her to stay
again
the more bodies a girl has so the more
people she's being with yeah it's the
hardest part it's harder for her to pay
a bond and be with you long term yeah so
if you're saving yourself for the wife
you bet you better want to go that's a
very ideally yeah ideally yeah but i
know the realities of this world in this
society
you won't really find that yeah but you
wouldn't find a man that's 25 black in
london chilling as a virgin bro it's
normal your acting is wrong but an
anomaly as well it's rare so look for
your anomaly don't say okay i'm going to
sacrifice thank you wait wait wait look
for your anomaly that's why i'm single
right and um i was actually watching a
video today as a matter of fact on ken
kendra g yeah kendrick had a woman on
her show he was 38
and a virgin
right and she was saying that she's been
looking for a man
and she wants a man of god and she it
was a christian thing right so i'm like
all right cool respect it but she's 38
and she's never had sex and she's not
she hasn't been in a serious
relationship have you been in a serious
relationship i haven't seen this
relationship yeah you're in one now no i
have been in one i'm not in one now but
i've been in one so when the serious
relationship start started sorry
how come it didn't lead to the place
where
because i told the person i was with
from the beginning this is this is what
i'm on this is what i'm doing and i'm
not i'm talking as if it's
it's like easy it's like yeah the the
thoughts don't come up or
the the
the the the temptation is not there
that's not what i'm saying of course how
tall are you
six three why okay i just want to put
that out there for the ladies out there
my point is here it's not like there's
not like it's the temptations are not
there but we're all human yeah we're all
human so the temptations is there but
that's what i was that's what i'm saying
to you about about intentions and why
you do things i already know what i'm
doing while i'm doing what i'm doing i
already know like this is what i this is
what i want to be ideally i want to find
someone who's also on the same page as
me compatibility i think it says that
there's something that i admire in that
but there's also something that's a
little bit naive in that
for me right
um because you're living in a world yeah
where you get eaten up
like
you will get eaten alive man like
by women women out here will see listen
women out here will see that oh my god
it's innocent oh my god and they will
come into your life bro and they will
eat you alive the women out here a lot
of the women out here
in these days and times bro
we have a very very special uh super
chat from um the the host she says stop
waffling these hoes
because if you actually
think since i've been here since i've
got it if you actually calculate
everything i've seen i've been saying
yeah
it it portrays the man that i am yeah so
everything that i've said yeah it it
goes it contributes to the man i am so
me saying this now
shouldn't be shocking because if you
actually reflect back to what i've said
you can see that it matches what i'm
saying but i agree with that i agree you
are you are keeping it on the same level
i'm not gonna say you're not keeping on
the same level but
we have to be truthful with the girls
bro because
like the way i see it yeah the way i see
it here the society that we live in lies
the girls every single day they lie to
the girls like if you lie women by the
sand so they lie to the girls every
single day so i think if we're going to
have these conversations we have to keep
it real with the gallium
who's to say that your truth what you're
saying
you you want to be with you both want to
be multiple women like
like
there's a separation between me okay
okay i'll say you you both are okay with
stepping out that's your truth no i'm
not okay with stepping out you're you're
okay with what you said earlier the
polygamy that's the best way to put it
you're okay with plaguing me
he's saying that he is not that's your
truth that's his truth how is
what you're what he's saying lying how
it triggers
yeah yeah do you know my bro yeah
um
you see
when you understand women yeah women
generally and i was i was talking on the
show about it i was on the show talking
about it the other day um
you know women want a man with sexual
experience generally they want a man who
is experienced sexually
um
because when it comes to sex women want
to be satisfied sexually um and like i
said a man can have sex with a hole in
the wall and be satisfied he doesn't
even know who's on the other side he's
fine do you get what i'm saying but when
it comes to women having sex right um
they want to be they want to know they
want to be satisfied and that actually
asks i think i was on the show with you
jess and we were saying would you want a
man who's a virgin
and just and i really believe you were
like no
that actually be quiet
i didn't want to say that
you're too hot but what i'm trying to
say is like this world yeah the reason
why the most powerful men have got women
yeah is because they've shown that they
can get women
so what i'm saying to you kudos to them
so what i'm trying to say is
women when you understand the psychology
of women women generally want a man who
knows what he's doing when it comes to
sex so
i'm not trying to disrespect you in any
way shape or form but what i'm saying is
in this world that we're living in right
now you might be hard-pressed
to find a woman who's cool with a man
who has no sexual experience